unidad total sobre ucrania después de
una llamada de 80 minutos con los
líderes europeos la otan
joe biden dijo a los periodistas que la
alianza occidental está unida he tenido
una muy muy muy buena conversación
unanimidad total con todos los líderes
europeos en medio de los temores de un
plan de rusia para invadir ucrania el
presidente de eeuu ha puesto a unos
8.500 soldados estadounidenses en alerta
en caso de necesidad podrían desplegarse
para ayudar a la cerca de cuatro mil
tropas de la otan en los países bálticos
y a las cinco mil tropas estadounidenses
y de la otan que ya están en polonia
estamos estudiando la posibilidad de
reforzar aún más nuestra presencia en la
parte oriental de la alianza lo que
podría incluir el despliegue de grupos
de combate adicionales de la otan más de
100.000 soldados rusos y adrián ucrania
por el norte el este y el sur pero rusia
niega estar planeando una invasión con
las tensiones elevadas los estados
miembros de la otan están realizando
maniobras de precaución dinamarca en una
fragata y desplegó cuatro aviones de
caza a lituania españa ofreció en el
heads a bulgaria y barcos al mar negro
los países bajos enviarán dos aviones de
guerra a bulgaria mientras que estonia
letonia y lituania enviaron misiles
antitanques y antiaéreos a ucrania y
francia enviaría tropas a rumanía el
portavoz de vladimir putin declaró a los
medios rusos que la otan y eeuu eran los
culpables de la escalada de tensiones
está generosamente aderezada con una
gran cantidad de información falsa el
gobierno francés anunció que
funcionarios rusos ucranianos franceses
y alemanes se reunirán en parís el
miércoles para intentar sacar
diplomáticamente a europa del este del
abismo